so you also did only fans as you
mentioned and uh I read on a website so
this is very investigative reporting
that uh on some months you've made uh
over a hundred thousand dollars on only
fans how did that feel great really
great
I mean like uh
well actually because so much you're
upbringing you didn't have money it's a
struggle with the factory job and so on
um maybe a good person to ask can uh
money by happiness
uh well I mean I think you get like a
resting set point of Happiness
regardless of how much money you have
but money can buy being less stressed I
would say
is there a lot of variation in the um
in the basic rest happiness for humans
in general like is that is that a good
thing to think about I mean they've done
some studies but again like again I'm
not sure I haven't actually read the
study so maybe they didn't replicate
where like they measured people before
and after winning a bunch of money to
see if their happiness is higher yeah I
think like it's by some measures it
wasn't by some it wasn't no I mean like
basically almost genetically so nature
nurture but
is there let's say after you're 18 is
there like some stable
level of happiness
that all the environmental genetic
factors combine to create so that
everything that life throws at you
uh has to face that happiness I think
you mentioned earlier that I seem to be
happy with a lot of stuff so maybe I
have a certain level do other people
have a lower level some people have
higher level yeah definitely like is
there is that a useful or
is that a useful model of human beings
or is it all ups and downs
like is it all like I mean there's no
combo right like I don't know some
people just are happier than others in
general and other people aren't but then
you also have ups and downs like I'm
sure you've experienced sadness
sometimes and happiness the other times
like if I actually were to integrate so
to have an integral under the area under
the onto the Curve I don't know if I'm
different than other people maybe I'm
just like really focused on the happy
moments and maybe feel the doubt moments
most intensely and maybe that like
on average it's all the same is that
possible I mean maybe
I just I I don't know like I remember
when I was a kid my mom would call me
Pollyanna all the time it's always like
finding the good and everything oh yeah
really like something better you were a
happy kid I was really happy kid yeah
even in uh in the harsh conditions yeah
I mean like I said like I think the
harshness comes from the bad meaning
like and I had good meaning applied to
it you were a stoic yeah with another
book I'm reading next week tune in
Marcus Aurelius meditations
all right all right uh camming 100K so
it felt good so
it's crazy though right you can just
like
take clothes off in a creative way with
some gnomes and make a hundred thousand
yeah I mean there's a lot more to it
than that but yeah what was it what's it
what's the difference
like so with with only with my free cams
I was unusual and that I decided to do
outside of the website marketing I like
post on Reddit right this was very
unusual at the time but like only fancy
structured such that uh they have almost
no internal Discovery whatsoever so if
you want people to come to your page you
have to go out on the external websites
and advertise for yourself directly very
different model and so this is something
that I had already been doing and
already had practicing and so I think I
was like already quite Advanced like I
already had an account on Reddit that
was like seven years old at the time
tons of like Karma that means I could
post in subreddits I already been on
Twitter for years you know like posting
actively so like I already had like
presences on all these other platforms
that really helped with the conversion
Reddit and Twitter Reddit Twitter
FetLife Instagram Tick Tock and you are
still advertising creatively so like
there's like sexuality but there's also
like creative sexuality yeah and ideas
too yeah like one of the really popular
ones was I like molested myself as a as
a mime using a uh a one arm through a
jacket and so the jacket looked like it
was
uh which actually looked like it was
alive and you know that one did really
well
did you like brainstorm with somebody
and like I recently got to hang out with
Mr Beast and I said uh uh on a session
of brainstorming different ideas
I just envisioned you with like a team
brainstorming all right how about we try
the mime and the molesting thing I don't
know it's too too edgy
I wish I think the tea would were fun
but no it's just me like I had an
apartment that looked like kind of like
this you know you just sit alone you're
like well that would be a good idea and
I'd seen you should collect ideas over
time right like
um I'd seen somebody doing a version of
the like this this animated hand act
like when I was a kid and I just always
stuck in my head and like one day I was
like I bet I could do that and then I
was thinking trying to think of ideas to
do as a sex worker I was like why don't
I just try that and then it turned out
to be like like a really like quite a
viral hit is there um is there stuff
like you mentioned to edgy like Mr Beast
tries to keep it PG yeah do you try to
keep it PG-13 well with the sex
advertising stuff I mean it's sex
advertising so it's obviously not PG-13
I don't know these ratings what is even
beyond that family friendly it is X like
even though the one that I'm describing
to you at some point like you can see my
boob so there's a boom is is ex my boob
is I guess it's not hard I think you can
show a boom in bg30 yeah maybe X is like
if you got some sort of rhythmic motion
going on
maybe that sound but the rhythmic was
actually not
you could have one or the other but you
can't have both you have both that's
when we hit the X
so definitely not paper I mean with the
sex advertising stuff like guys like
vanilla [__] guys want basic hot girl
you can do something like kind of sexy
and creative like getting abducted by
gnomes or like the self molestation
right but those are still pretty within
the normal boundaries
what do you mean guys like vanilla stuff
I mean most guys like vanilla stuff
what's Vanilla stuff like see I'll talk
about fetish
fetishes I think my uh Overton window on
what is vanilla is expanding
quickly after following your work but
yeah I actually have done a lot of
studies on what is vanilla like I've
done a couple different surveys where I
ask people like how taboo is this thing
and I have like a rating from least to
miss taboo by the way I don't like I
don't appreciate the beauty of vanilla
ice cream you don't it is really good
though
you eat vanilla ice cream I eat vanilla
ice cream yeah I think there's just so
many more options it's like the absence
of creativity I mean if you put in like
some chocolate chips or something
now they already made it more
interesting
um to start okay so what's Vanilla what
and why do guys like vanilla so hot girl
doing hot girl things what like
undressing and then yeah sex the thing
that I found was most successful were
frames where the man was framed as
passive and the woman is active or like
for example uh like oh you know we got
assigned to the same bunk uh at the
breeding school or something or like oh
we're the last people on earth right or
like oh no uh you know I like I
desperately need somebody to like cure
me with this disease and I need semen so
it's like in any scenario where the guys
just like finds himself such that the
woman like desperately needs him for
some reason and he doesn't have to do
much that is like typically one of the
much more successful things like guys
like women falling into their lap what
about the power Dynamic
um so guys are less into power dynamics
than women are and you can do power
dynamics as long as it's like handed to
them some guys obviously some guys are
like very dominant like prefer like
having to work but this is the minority
like if you're trying to do make 100K in
a month and you're trying to appeal the
whitest group of people the most
effective advertising you're not gonna
be making the most money by being like
particularly submissive so on the
camping side that's your uh unlike a
like uh escorting or just personal
relationships you're trying to you have
an audience
you have like a theater full of people
like with live camming you have a live
camera yeah it's like a live theater is
that freak you out there's just a bunch
of people watching I mean what how do
you feel right now I don't I don't know
their watch because it's not live yeah
that's true it's not live so like it
might as well be like they could be
watching
I feel like there's just the two of us I
don't know and there's like I feel
sometimes I imagine there's a third
person like God usually no no not not
God just I usually imagine
um
either a guy or girl or a couple just
sitting there for some reason like
usually on the beach and usually high or
on some kind of like about mushrooms
just like listening passively just kind
of looking at the sunset that's what I
imagine well that's really good yeah I
think it's useful like when I write my
blog posts sometimes I do terribly but
it's the most effective when I imagine
one person that I'm writing to to try to
explain and like having a high couple
watching the sunset is maybe really
lovely as a calibration I have to say it
is pretty romantic
because I've gotten a chance to meet
couples that listen to podcasts together
um I don't know why that seems like
intensely romantic to me because like
because you're not watching TV together
you're listening to a thing I guess
sometimes they watch it but like you're
listening to ideas together
I don't know it seems like you're going
through the same kind of thought process
yeah yeah that's a really beautiful way
to put it so it's like you're melding
your thinking is following the same life
some of our podcasts do that more than
movies I think movies give you a lot
more freedom to think about stuff I feel
like your thoughts are aligned and like
especially if the if the podcast is good
like if it's listening to
um like a Dan Carlin podcast about
history that you're like on a journey
together
ah is there's an intimacy to that